well just a day before Thanksgiving
police are investigating the mysterious
circumstances surrounding the apparent
deaths of a family member at New York
New Jersey mansion a fire broke out
yesterday at the property in Colts Neck
where first responders found four bodies
the victims names have not been released
but records show the mansion was owned
by a technology industry CEO Don Dahler
is near the scene in Colts Neck Don good
morning good morning this small safe
community just outside of New York City
is home to the wealthy Bruce Springsteen
lives here Jon Stewart has property here
but authorities are now saying that the
fire at that mansion you can barely see
through those trees they are
investigating it as possible arson early
Tuesday afternoon firefighters raced to
put out flames ripping through a more
than 5,000 square foot mansion in the
wealthy New Jersey suburb of Colts Neck
Monmouth County property records show
the mansion built in 2003 is owned by
Keith Kinnear oh and his wife Jennifer
records show two years ago they paid off
a more than 1.8 million dollar mortgage
on the home one body that was found out
front of the home the other three were
recovered from inside the home a source
told nj.com it was Kinnear OHS body
found outside the mansion on the front
lawn the 50 year old allegedly suffered
a gunshot wound that did not appear to
be self-inflicted a source told nj.com
the badly burned bodies found inside the
home or Jennifer and the couple's two
young children we have no reason to
believe that the community is in any
danger at this point in time according
to his online profiles Connie row is a
graduate of Columbia University and the
CEO of the tech company square one he
also operates a pest control company and
is a realtor very nice very friendly
anybody that you'd want to be living
next door to basically earlier Tuesday
there was a fire at another home in
Ocean Township about 10 miles from the
Colts Neck mansion no one was hurt
property records show the home is owned
by Paul Kinnear
nj.com reports he is Keith's brother is
it related to the one that's gone going
right now that remains to be seen but
that is an option or an angle that that
we continue to pursue
we reached out to the prosecutor's
office for comment but have not yet
heard back from him now nj.com had a few
more details
Paul the brother Paul was seen at the
site of the fire at his house and was
visibly distraught nj.com also reports
that the brothers grew up in Brooklyn
and the Keith was the best man at Paul's
wedding we have reached out to Paul and
have not heard back from him yet either
John fascinating mystery Thank You Don